ich habe gerade den nachbarn umgebracht
fühlt sich ehrlich gesagt gar nicht so
besonders sein
meine hand blutet jetzt und das ist das
einzige was mich gestört vielleicht
wirklich noch ein nachbar über macht das
gleiche wie ging es dann hat er viel
schmerzen gehabt war der schnell
bewusstlos dass er nicht so viel
mitgekriegt hat hat er angst gehabt
wollte dass seine mama bei ihm ist das
sind so sachen die wirklich immer extrem
viel durchgehen morgen stücke teilen wie
auch immer man das nennen wir verteilt
im raum
das sind täter die eiskalt sind sie sind
berechnen sie haben keine gefühle sowie
im schweigen der lämmer hatte überlegte
wut hass ich habe alles eher mehr an
gefühlen die man zu haben
[Musik]
die hatten es mit einem sehr brutalen
mörder zu tun was aber besonders war an
dieser sache erst mit seinen taten
gerühmt da hab ich jetzt zwei morde
offen hatte bekam ich einen brief von
ihm
[Musik]